The Joe Rogan Experience have you
followed the the Jaguar debate that's
going on right now no
um it's a great one man so
defining it's one of it Jag okay we're a
backup
I'm gonna tell you an imperial like I'm
gonna tell you something that's like
objectively true okay
okay it's objectively true
that we had
a population of jaguars
in the United States of America
um up until the 1800s right it's just
they just were
what's debated is uh was it how how
stable was it how widespread was it some
people would point to well like
basically limited to Southern Arizona
some people would look and and be well
West Texas New Mexico
Southern Arizona what about members of
the Coronado Expedition drawing a
distinction between
lions and jaguars
all the way up like toward the Platte
River
okay like why would they say both
um you know I mean like what are they
confusing where's the Platte River oh so
in the in the in the more in the
Southern Plains the southern Great
Plains of the United States flowing
across Kansas okay oh wow
where you have instances of people
mentioning things that you sort of like
looking at like man they got if they
weren't talking about Jaguar what the
hell they talking about how do they
describe it leopards
um okay and and a lot of times someone
will say there'll be a reference to a
large cat and you can't rule out well
maybe in the historic record they're
probably talking about mountain lions
but what do you do in a case where you
have a historic record and someone is in
some Oddball play Southern Colorado and
they're talking about they have lions
and leopards oh wow and lions and
leopards so it's like
I guess we're talking I mean they got me
they have to be referring to Jaguars
right much more widely dispersed so as
as people get into talking about Jaguar
recovery of which I'm a
I'm I'm a proponent with an asterisk
when people get talking about Jaguar
recovery you have to Define what that
looks like
and there are some who would say jaguar
recovery in North America as a
collaborative effort between us Mexico
Belize whoever else is rolled into this
Jaguar recovery plan Jaguar recovery in
North America would mean
recovering them across core habitat okay
that's the term you hear all the time
like core habitat so then you got to
argue over what is the line what's core
habitat for Jaguars and some people will
argue and many of them have motivation
some of them are honest some of them
have other kind of you know political
motivation to say that core habitat is
not Arizona
that was always Fringe stray males one
or two here and there long periods of
absence it wasn't core habitat other
people would argue that Arizona was
absolutely core habitat and if we're
going to restore Jaguars and core
habitat we're going to be restoring
Jaguars in some portion of the lower 48.
um meaning eventually
and and Recovery would look a couple
ways one is like protections and you
would watch how Jaguars are able to flow
back and forth across the border
a big question around Jaguar recovery is
the border wall okay how much would uh
how much would a border wall impact
large mammal movements so that's an
aspect if we don't allow recovery in
that way we make recovery in that way
difficult do we truck Jaguars up and
turn them loose in Arizona New Mexico
West Texas really
you're going to turn them loose right
I love it dude I love them and I
honestly don't think um
you know they they like live in such low
population
abundances and they have such huge home
ranges I don't think it would ever be
that there was like a Jaguar problem
there's no Jaguar problem yeah I don't
think you're gonna have people you know
the Kate where where you know you might
recover wolves in some area and lose
two-thirds of the elk like seemingly
overnight I just I can't picture that
that's I think you'd lose a lot of lions
you'd lose a lot of mountain lions
probably but do you think they'd be
forced out I think due to predation I
think that probably a comment I think a
combination of both like them killing
them and then just range reduction
because of this big cat but dude I like
I'm I'm a conflict averse enough where I
don't want it's like Trucking them into
me is way in the future
um and man it would be a political
battle and you'd make a spotted owl out
of the Jaguar
um you'd have some level of people that
just came to hate them sons of [ __ ]
because they were a symbol of federal
overreach
but them just coming across the border I
think is a great way it's a great thing
to root for
well that's where they think El Jefe is
coming through yeah that's one of the
reasons why they call them El Jefe he
manages to make his way through the wall
yep and there's but it you know for a
Jaguar to come hanging out in the U.S
it's it's uh you know it's a dicey life
I don't think he knows no no of course
no of course he doesn't know but
you wind up uh there's not like a great
in recent decades there's not a great
likelihood of finding uh of establishing
a habitat and having a female to breed
with